and we're talking about Transportation
I'm here with my wife's boyfriend it's
just ridiculous that you you guys are
going to persecute him because he's a
black man that's why you guys are doing
this this way you're bringing so much
attention to him when we walked in here
it was absolutely unreal the amount of
security that he went through compared
to the amount of security that I went
through and this is my wife's boyfriend
I mean the things that he does to my
wife is incredible and we're talking
about Transportation let's talk about
Pete butterjudge the transportation
secretary and he's the best secretary
I've ever had because he's a homosexual
and as a matter of fact that's why I
started to become bisexual to be more
like Pete Buddha judge and that's why
I've started to have a relationship with
men on the side and that's why I have
grinder so listen we need to get Federal
funding uh selvina is that how I say her
name selvina Brooks Powers
um we got to get some federal funding
from people to judge because listen Joe
Biden's over there I know his son's
smoking crack in the Ukraine but that
doesn't matter I mean Pete butterjudge
you know I know he's like on a gay
cruise with his husband and they're you
know like breastfeeding their babies and
stuff but they can help the
transportation issues we're having here
in New York I mean that's the federal
Boss Dog on Primetime 99 I'm a pimp on a
blimp so I wrote this song New York City
is so dang bad
this apple is rotten
what have we gotten nothing but violence
all I hear is Silence from all leaders
my man's titties are out and they are
bleeders because they get cut with a
knife he sleeps with my wife this city
is damned too expensive to get an
apartment we need to lower the rent but
instead we're going to charge these poor
drivers more money but all I want to do
is get vaccinated stick that vaccine in
my arm I want to vaccinate with this
love charm I love you guys I'm Primetime
99 Sylvia and my wife's boyfriend has a
lot of issues and you know I just hate
these trucks when they're trying to take
a nap and I'm playing Xbox and they're
trying to make love these these trucks
are making too much noise and they're
just polluting too much gas and they're
just making it difficult for my wife and
you know her boyfriend on Terrace to
really enjoy that thank you but you
everybody else got to speak past the
time limit so I just have a couple more
minutes so what I'm saying is in this
city we have serious issues and my songs
aren't going to solve it and we have
Eric Adams in the nightclub you know
doing God knows what sir if you're not
going to stay on topic I can't talk
about Eric Adams is he not on topic
we're talking about truck routes that's
what I'm saying so is Eric Adams not in
charge of the city is he not in charge
I'm not finished I'm not finished I just
understand what everybody else gets to
come here and pontificate for five ten
minutes and I try to talk about
something and you try to shut me down
why is it because I'm a homosexual is it
because I'm bisexual thank you is that
why
I think they don't like that I'm
bisexual
all right
anyway guys thank you so much
um I'm Igbo please help the homeless uh
it's a serious situation out there I
have to deal with the you know the the
trucks and all that as I'm trying to
sleep on a box on 42nd and I think it
should be addressed uh homeless people
are people too and um I'm a veteran of
this country titties and all
those are veteran titties Alex people
may be wondering what do you mean your
wife's boyfriend uh dontarius before we
get into the specifics of the content
there which was you know there's a lot
to talk about
well yes obviously for the people that
are playing at home I'll in professional
wrestling we call it Cafe that's why the
Undertaker stays in character but I'll
I'll give you guys because we're on the
great Dave Rubin report this great
program I'm doing my trump I'm saying uh
because we're here I'll break the cave
I'm not married and uh dantarius is not
really my wife's boyfriend but what I'm
trying to mock is there's so many people
in content creators guys like Destiny
and and really there's just a ton of
people that it's like cuckold Society
where they just let their wife or
girlfriend be on only fans so really
that's kind of what I'm mocking and when
people hear it they laugh but I'm trying
to actually kind of bring attention to
the fact that literally we have a
society of like these demasculinized men
where they just let their wife do
whatever they want and that's happening
this polyamorous you know it's just it's
it's a little more common than we like
to say like to think and then when I say
it like that it kind of makes people
wonder you know what's really going on
with people's relationships and it's
funny it's just funny to say my wife
yeah that's what I said If you're
looking for more enlightening and maybe
even humorous conversations check out
our comedy play list and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
Bell